Death penalty cases if no court grants
relief for reverses the sentence into an
execution.
Uh,
the United States all,
most,
all of the states now have
gone to lethal injection.
Uh,
there's been this procession of what's
the most humane way to execute people,
uh,
is that the firing squad he said,
hanging,
uh,
and the 1880s,
the governor of New York said that hanging
was barbaric and New York was going
to the electric chair.
Uh,
by,
uh,
you know,
the,
the late part of the 20th century,
most people saw the electric
chair is being barbaric.
States also use the gas chamber,
uh,
to execute people.
But today,
uh,
the predominant way of executing
people in the United States is lethal
injection.
Uh,
it was seen as a,
you know,
more humane,
almost a medically type,
uh,
putting somebody to sleep,
like as if they were going
to have an operation.
But,
uh,
what we've seen in the last 40 years is
that lethal injection is not without its
problems.
Uh,
the case of a Ranell broom
a is a good case in point.
Uh,
he was set for execution by Ohio.
they tried repeatedly to
inject him with a lethal drugs.
He even helped them by trying to find a,
a place to be injected.
Uh,
this went on for hours
before they finally gave up,
and he was not,
uh,
lethally injected.
Uh,
in 2014 there were executions
in which one person said,
I feel like my whole body's on fire.
Uh,
after the lethal drugs started
running into their body.
And another case,
uh,
the person made a lot of groaning and
guttural noises and twisted around for a
while before finally dying.
And so there's,
there's a controversy,
uh,
about,
what drugs should be used in this process.
Uh,
the availability of the drugs,
uh,
the qualifications of the people
who carry out the executions.
I mean,
a doctors will not carry out an execution
because of the hippocratic oath.
So the result is that often
a prison guards or maybe mts,
uh,
emergency medical technicians are the
ones who are inserting the needle into the
arm of the person.
Uh,
in Missouri,
it turned out that the person who was
in charge of lethal injections was
dyslexic dyslectic,
uh,
and was often,
operating in a little dark
room using a flashlight,
a telling other people how to
mix the drugs up and all that,
and was not being done with
any degree of precision at all.
Uh,
which,
which was alarming to the courts
as well as to to people in general.
Uh,
and the secrecy after,
uh,
the practices like that came to
light like the Missouri practices,
uh,
and after,
the suppliers and many of the drugs,
the suppliers and many of the drugs
pentobarbital and others in Europe,
uh,
increasingly,
would not make those drugs
available in the United States,
uh,
or wouldn't make them available if
they were going to be used for lethal
injection.
The result being that states
have had more and more trouble,
uh,
had more and more trouble finding
drugs to put people to death with,
uh,
some states,
notably Georgia,
uh,
important.
Some drugs from a somewhat fly by night.
A pharmacy that operated out
of a driving school in London,
uh,
was later a sees those drugs were
later sees by the Drug Enforcement
Administration,
uh,
which found that Georgia had illegally
imported the drugs and secondly had
illegally distributed the drugs,
uh,
to some other states.
Uh,
increasingly state started
using compounding pharmacies,
uh,
that is these local pharmacies
that put the drugs together.
Uh,
one judge by Judge Kermit by on the eight
circuit said some of these are about
equivalent of a high
school chemistry class.
And so there's been issues about whether
or not these compounding pharmacies can
actually provide drugs that
are effective for doing this.
Uh,
in response to that,
a lot of states have made
the whole process secret.
So you can't challenge it if
you don't know what's going on.
Uh,
if you don't know who's
carrying out the execution,
you don't know whether
they're qualified or not.
Uh,
some states have even gone so far
as to say the source of the drugs,
the compounding pharmacy is secret.
Everything is secret.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so the question is,
can you eliminate the legal issue,
uh,
just simply by cloaking the
whole process and secrecy?
Uh,
it doesn't really give one a
lot of confidence in the system.
The notion of a democracy is transparency,
uh,
but increasingly departments of
corrections are going to secrecy,
uh,
as a way to hide exactly what they're
doing in the lethal injection process.
A one stage justified this by saying,
well,
used to be a that the
hangman always wore a hood.
Uh,
so you didn't know who the hangman was.
but it's a little bit different when
you're buying drugs from a pharmacy a than
when you're the person who
actually carries out the
execution and might not want
all your neighbors to,
to know about it.
Um,
Kentucky,
uh,
lawyers in Kentucky for a
person condemned to die.
Actually a couple of people
condemned to die raised,
uh,
the legality of lethal injection and a
case called Bayes versus Reese that went
before the supreme court in 2008,
uh,
the court rejected the argument looking
at a lot of its other cases and the
eighth amendment area in which
methods of execution had been upheld.
A firing squad had been upheld,
the electric chair had been upheld.
Uh,
and basically the court said,
and sort of a splintered court,
uh,
justice chief justice Roberts joined
by Justice Kennedy and Alito said,
the risk of pain is not so substantial
an eminent as to violate the eighth
amendment.
I should back up here and say the argument
that was being made on behalf of the
condemned men in this case,
uh,
was that they were,
being paralyzed.
Uh,
and then these additional drugs
were being forced into their body.
Uh,
and if they were experiencing
excruciating pain a while these drugs,
we're acting upon them
until they finally stop,
stop the beating of the heart,
uh,
that would be cruel and unusual punishment
that would be unnecessary suffering
for,
it's very hard.
They were expert testimony saying that
it was very possible that this could
happen,
particularly if you had
people administering the
drugs that didn't know what
they were doing.
Because if you administered
the wrong dose,
the first drug would induce
sleep or put the person,
make the person unconscious.
Uh,
the second drug would paralyze the person
would eventually cause suffocation if
nothing else happened.
But then the final drug,
uh,
was,
to stop the beating of the heart.
Uh,
but the,
the question was whether when
that drug was administered,
the person could,
could feel what was going on or not.
Uh,
Roberts,
Kennedy,
Alito say,
uh,
that,
Kentucky is doing enough.
They're minimizing the chance that
anything is going to go wrong.
Uh,
and they're not required.
The,
there may be a better way to do it,
but it states aren't required
to do it the best way.
Uh,
they're just required not to take a,
uh,
they certainly can involve the
gratuitous infliction of pain,
uh,
and they can't take a substantial
risk of that kind of thing happening.
Well,
justice Stevens,
uh,
said that under the court's
proceed under the prior cases,
he thought it was acceptable.
He also took the opportunity here to
say that based on his many years on the
court,
he had come to the conclusion that the
death pulling no longer a was serving
anything but negligible value.
That the purpose lists
taking of human life was,
uh,
making only the most marginal
contributions to society.
And therefore,
uh,
probably,
was,
was disproportionate unconstitutional.
Uh,
this was very late in his career on the,
on,
on the court,
uh,
Justice Scalia and Thomas said,
unless it was deliberately cruel,
there was no problem.
So unless the state was trying to
inflict a punishment that was curl,
no constitutional problem.
Uh,
justice Bryer,
uh,
said that based on his reading and things,
Kentucky,
uh,
method did not result in an
unnecessary risk of suffering a,
so he concurred.
Uh,
but Justice Ginsburg,
uh,
joined by Justice Souter descended,
saying that in their view,
uh,
the Kentucky,
procedures were not adequate.
They were eighth amendment
grounds that were raised.
Uh,
but those were just
two out of seven votes.
Uh,
so it looked like at the time
that bass came down there,
this is pretty much the end of any
challenges to lethal injection.
This is in 2008,
but since that time,
uh,
there have continued to be and probably
will continue to be a number of
challenges,
uh,
to lethal injection,
in Kentucky when this case went back
when bays versus Reese went back to
Kentucky,
it was pointed out that they had to
go through the Kentucky Administrative
Procedures Act,
uh,
to set up a new execution protocol.
And so all of the executions were put on
hold until such time as that was done.
That was also,
uh,
done in California,
ending sort of stop it.
There were already,
uh,
litigation about lethal
injection in California.
And this added one more element to that.
Uh,
there's also,
uh,
questions about the
compounding pharmacies,
questions about the secrecy,
uh,
all of those kinds of things.
So,
uh,
while lethal injection was seen as
a way to make the death penalty more
acceptable,
uh,
it hasn't quite turned out that way.
Uh,
some states have even thought about
going back to the firing squad.
Uh,
and of course if it's in,
it's really the only way to ensure
the death of a person that's quick,
painless,
uh,
and so forth.
Hard.
Imagine Utah still uses a firing squad.
Some other states are talking
about bringing it back.
Uh,
I suppose one other,
uh,
method of execution that might
be considered as the guillotine,
which also was very fast,
uh,
and,
didn't result in any lingering pain or
any of the risks involved with lethal
injection.
Uh,
but we're probably not going to go there
and probably not going to go to the
firing squad either.
Some states have also said they'll
fall back on electrocution if need be.
But other states like Georgia
have declared electrocution
unconstitutional under
its state constitution.
Uh,
so that's not an option.
So,
uh,
again,
lethal injection was supposed to make
capital punishment more acceptable,
more anesthetic.
Uh,
it,
it hasn't quite worked out that way.
Yeah.